لقد انهار البلد ،
فقد أضاف الوباء الطمع إلى هؤلاء مشكلة كبيرة جدًا
نعتقد أنها
ستزداد سوءًا إذا كان الوضع في
البلد بأكمله سيئًا للغاية
في الشمال وخاصة في طرابلس ،
إنه أسوأ بكثير ، إنه بسبب العديد من العوامل
كما تعلم
تعتبر طرابلس أفقر
مدينة
في البحر الأبيض المتوسط ، ولدينا نسبة عالية من
لبطالة ، حوالي 60 إ
ى 70 بالمائة في الواقع شخ
عاطل عن العمل ، إنها عائلة بأكملها بد
ن تغطية طبية بدون دخل بد
ن تعليم ، لذا فإن الوباء الشائع ال
ي نواجهه بدأ بالفعل با
ضبط  قبل عام واحد ، عانينا من
العديد من المشاكل التي عانينا منها الكثير من إغلاق
بعضها البعض بشكل كامل ولكن لم
يتم احترامها في طرابلس ، ويرجع ذلك إلى
الوضع الاقتصادي السيئ الذي يتعين على الناس العمل
فيه يوميًا للحصول على أموالهم
ولديهم خيارات للموت  من
الجوع
أو كيف أثر هذا الغموض السياسي
والدمار المالي الذي
يواجه لبنان بشكل خاص
على النظام الصحي و
أخبرني في مستشفاك بما يحدث في
مستشفاك على أساس يومي
كيف تتعامل مع
العديد من المشاكل كما أخبرتك
أن
المشكلة الرئيسية هي عدم وجود فرق طبية
كل يوم لدينا عدد كبير من
يغادر أطبائنا البلدان التي ليس لدينا
ما
يكفي من
الممرضات للاستمرار في
النشاط اليومي الذي نواجهه مع عدد كبير
من مرضى كوبي لدينا
مشكلة يومية للتعامل مع كل هذا
النقص في المعدات
[موسيقى  ]
أدوية أم زيت غاز ، ربما
معدات شخصية ، إنها مشكلة صعبة حقًا ،
دكتورة نزرين
، أنفق البنك الدولي
34 مليون دولار لتمويل
حملة اللقاح 19 السرية في لبنان
بشرط أن تذهب الجرعات
إلى الفئات الأكثر ضعفًا أولاً ،
والآن انتهك المشرعون في لبنان
ذلك  التعامل من خلال القفز على اللقاح
استجابةً لذلك
، هدد المدير الإقليمي للبنك الدولي
بسحب التمويل ، مما يشير إلى
استمرار الفساد
والمحسوبية من
خلال طرح اللقاح.
في
التأثير على لبنان على أولئك
الذين يحتاجون بوضوح ويجب أن يحصلوا على هذه
اللقاحات
في الوقت الحالي ، إنه انتهاك عزيزي ،
إنه أمر طبيعي ، إنها
حقيقة اعتدنا عليها في
نشاطنا اليومي في لبنان ، إنها ليست
الانتهاك
الوحيد للتطعيم ، فهناك الكثير  العديد من
المشاكل التي نواجهها في الواقع ،
هل تتخيل أننا لا نملك
لقاحًا كافيًا للطاقم الطبي ،
لقد بدأنا التطعيم منذ ثلاثة أسابيع
وحتى الآن لم
يتم تطعيم طاقمنا الطبي بالكامل ، لم يتم تطعيم الخطوط الأمامية لدينا
بشكل كامل لذلك
لدينا الكثير  من المشاكل التي
بدأناها دون إشراك القطاع الخاص ،
لا أعتقد أنه يمكننا إدارة
هذا الحجم الكبير